this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks me for the introduction thank you
everyone for coming today I'm Angela and
I'm going to be sharing some research
plans and some preliminary results for
my PhD work here which is focusing on
nano scale characterization of carbon
mineral interfaces particularly in
intact soil micro aggregates so to start
on the very broad scale these are just
some values of carbon stocks and various
parts of the global carbon budget and
soil as we know is a fairly large stock
of carbon especially compared to
vegetation it's commonly stated to be
about three times the content of carbon
in the atmosphere so this really
relatively large stock is important for
the overall carbon budget and whether
carbon and soil is increased or
decreased or state stays consistent is a
really important factor for overall
carbon balance so this is just a global
soil organic carbon distribution and
from here on I'll be focusing on organic
carbon showing in northern permafrost
really high carbon concentrations in
blue but I also like to focus on some
more hotspots of high carbon content in
this case I'd like to talk mostly about
volcanic soils in areas like the
Indonesia Mexico and particularly Hawaii
so now sue mning in to the island of
Hawaii the carbon content in volcanic
soils which are part of the andis all
soil order have a relatively high carbon
content compared to a lot of the other
soil orders and also based on
radiocarbon data a lot of the carbon is
very old meaning that it's fairly stable
in soil henna has been there for a long
time but this actually depends a bit on
the age of the soil so if you've
imagined a brand new lava deposit just
being a few hundred years
ranging to soils that have been
weathering for four million years
somewhere in the middle there's a peak
in the amount of carbon content and also
carbon age and this is a concept that
has been linked particularly with
mineral properties of that median age
soil and this is particularly apparent
in deeper horizons so this is a map of
carbon organic carbon content at a depth
of about 60 to 100 centimeters with a
red showing higher content and relative
to for instance the contiguous United
States you can see that deep soil
horizons in Hawaii and other volcanic
soils have much higher carbon content
and again this is linked with
particularly mineral properties in this
system and this is a really good example
of the overall relationship between
carbon stabilization and minerals and
this is apparent in many different
ecosystems with varying degrees of
importance dependent on that mineralogy
so this is a process that I like to
think about as ranging from the
ecosystem scale all the way down to the
scale is a few microns a few nanometers
at the actual interface of carbon and
minerals in soil so again in the example
of the volcanic soils you have an
ecosystem property mineralogy
and in these medium age soils they are
dominated by what we call short-range
ordered or semi crystalline minerals so
I'll refer to those kind of as both SRO
or semi crystalline minerals for the
rest of the talk and then moving down to
the nano scale there are properties at
the actual surface of these minerals
such as pH dependent charge and high
surface area that are related to their
carbon storage properties so I'm just
going to give a brief overview of some
of the proposed mechanisms of carbon
stabilization by minerals but an
important concept is that
the actual mechanism involved is very
specific to the mineral the type of
carbon present and also the
environmental factors that are at work
in that particular system so just one
example is a mechanism of ligand
exchange or an ion exchange for
stabilization of soil organic carbon by
the semi crystalline or short-range
ordered minerals that I mentioned
earlier in volcanic soils Alassane and a
Moga light being two examples of that
kind of mineral in addition to ligands
exchange and anion exchange just a few
other general interaction mechanisms
hydrophobic interactions hydrogen
bonding cation bridging general effects
of entropy and then a little bit less
direct sense actual surface
stabilization you can also have more
indirect effects of physical protection
by mineral facilitated aggregate
formation or stabilization and pores so
these are all just very general proposed
mechanisms of carbon stabilization by
minerals one of the more interesting
models of surface interactions is the
zonal model proposed by clubber where
you have an so philic molecules which
basically have a polar and in a nonpolar
end creating this kind of bilayer model
where you have the polar end interacting
with surface and then the long sort of
nonpolar tails interacting in a
hydrophobic zone and then lots of
potential interactions with the aqueous
solution on the kinetic zone so there
are many different proposed mechanisms
but why does that really make a
difference we know it's stabilized you
know why do we need to know how and I
think that it's really important because
the actual mechanism involved may
respond differently to changing
environmental variables increased
temperature increased moisture in
particular an example would be a
covalent or an
actual chemical bonds in Inner Sphere
complex formation for instance may
respond differently to to warmer
temperatures than say a weak hydrophobic
Association so knowing what kind of
mechanism is involved could be really
important for prediction of future soil
carbon stabilization and modeling for
instance currently all of these
mechanisms that I've mentioned are have
mostly been determined indirectly by
adsorption isotherm experiments for
example and currently they lack direct
observation and characterization in real
soils our Institute but what we do have
so far for analysis of carbon mineral
interfaces in soil has shown
unsurprisingly a very heterogeneous
distribution of carbon on the scale of
an aggregate and all the way down to the
scale of an actual mineral particle so
this image shows carbon and yellow and
this is NaN nano secondary ion mass
spectrometry and you can see that the
carbon is really distributed in discrete
patches and not distributed evenly over
the surface of the mineral and this
patchy distribution has also been
unserved all the way down to a single
mineral surface so this presents a
pretty substantial methodological
challenge for observation in terms of
both the spatial heterogeneity and also
chemical variability so to get a little
bit more into the methodological
challenges namely spatial resolution is
a huge limitation so some current
techniques such as next asked which is
near edge x-ray adsorption fine
structure which is a synchrotron based
technique has about a 25 to 50 nanometer
spatial resolution which is just too big
unbelievably it seems so small to
encompass the kind of variability that
we see in soil also some other
methodological challenges are the use of
a stable
material to actually make sense sections
which is often carbon-based so then it's
really hard to see carbon when you use a
carbon stabilizing resin also for
instance and in this study mineral
particles were kind of shaken up and
then distributed on a surface so you
don't maintain the spatial distribution
in an actual aggregate and then also in
general high energy analysis using an
electron beam or x-rays can create
sample damage so these are all things
that have to be considered for direct
observation so one method this is now
what I will be focusing on for the rest
of the talk is a combination of scanning
transmission electron microscopy or stem
and electron energy loss spectroscopy
lots of acronyms yield so just really
briefly eels involves the electron beam
from the microscope going into a very
thin cross-section sample and then some
of those electrons will just pass right
through and some of them will interact
with the material and then scatter and
so some of the scattering is inelastic
which means that it loses energy and so
you can measure that energy loss with a
spectrometer hence getting a collect
Ronn energy loss spectroscopy and that's
just basically how that works and then
when you get an energy loss spectrum you
have some distinctive peaks for certain
elements so this is for carbon which is
in diamond and graphite but then you
have a distinctive peak position and
shape or the fine structure which tells
you something about what that carbon is
bonded to so if it's bonded to oxygen
it's a double bond to another carbon
nitrogen you can get an idea of what
functional groups are there and what
their coordination might be this is an
image of stem eels of a Amazonian dark
earth that has a biochar particle but
this particular image shows an alumina
silicate clay and
and then iron oxide on the surface and
you can determine using eels that it's
oxidized iron or iron 3 based on the
intensity signals which I'll be talking
about later so yields is a really good
tool for both a very high resolution
ideally for a a homogeneous material the
resolution can be up to 0.2 nanometers
throughout 2 angstroms which is
unbelievably high for natural soils
probably not that good but that's kind
of the idea and then also be able to get
information about the the chemical
composition of the sample so it's a
really useful combination so now I'd
like to give an overview of the main
chapters or sections of my PhD research
so to start I'm going to be compiling a
library of sorts of Ile spectra for a
number of different soil minerals and
then also common model carbon in soil
and then building on that collect yield
data for simplified mixtures of carbon
and minerals and that will be designed
based on specific hypothesized
interactions that have interesting
spatial information in a in this case a
simplified system where the
environmental variables can be
controlled so redox potential or a pH
that somehow may be affecting the
interaction mechanism and then sort of
the end goal or the epitome of all of
this is applying the technique to real
soils in thin sections Wow importantly
maintaining spatial distribution in the
sample eliminating the use of
stabilizing materials or carbon resins
that would allow us to not be able to
analyze carbon and then also minimizing
sample damage so I'm kind of pursuing
each of these three things all at once
so I'll show you a few aspects of each
of them and then the next steps for each
as well so to start some of the
standards that I've chosen
are listed here and they represent a
range of elements I specifically am also
analyzing a volcanic soil minerals
allatheena and a mobile light for
instance as well as some other elements
calcium and phosphorus minerals and then
similarly for carbon there are many
different kinds of carbon present and
soil as we know and so I've selected a
list that cover a broad range of
functional group types and also some
that are specific to black carbon or a
biochar because I'm in Johannes Lehmann
so I just like to show you a couple of
reference spectra that I've collected so
far so these are for hematite and ger
tight both iron minerals hematite is an
iron oxide and Goethe and iron
oxyhydroxide so each of these particles
is ground very fine and then deposited
this lacy background is carbon that you
just deposit the materials on and then
you end up with some areas on the edges
that are thin enough for eels so the
whole particle is going to be way too
thick but you can get some kind of
regions on the edges before I start
showing a bunch of spectra that are not
going to mean a whole lot I just wanted
to give a quick overview of some of the
terminology so when you're talking about
next ass or eels you're talking about
KLM and n edges and these basically
correspond to the simplified Bohr model
of an atom the energy levels that you
can also see in your gen chem electron
configuration sort of representation so
you have your core electrons closer to
the nucleus that are your K and L edges
and those will require more energy to be
excited or to to move to the next energy
level and then out in the outer edges
you have the m and n which are more of
your valence electrons so those require
much lower energy this is a just a
simplified
maduk of an eel spectrum so right at
zero when you have a huge peak called a
zero loss peak which tells you how many
electrons just pass straight through
your sample and you want to know that
because you want to know that it's thin
enough to be able to use this technique
so that's a really important thing to
collect for all all of your spectra and
then you have this kind of indistinct
bump in the low loss region and so
that's indicating all of the those M&N
edges and your valence electrons and
there's a lot of overlap between
different elements in that region so
it's kind of hard to get really
qualitative information from that but
you can kind of confirm that okay well I
see the iron M edge so that means iron
is definitely present here but when you
start to move out into the higher energy
regions where you might be looking at
your carbon iron oxygen edges the
elements of interest that's where you
start to get a apparent peak for the
core loss and then all of this fine
structure that tells you something about
the binding environment of that element
so here is a spectrum for hematite and
Goethe if for iron so this is the iron l
edge now and on initial kind of
observation they look fairly similar
however even very small shifts can be
meaningful in terms of discerning
between different kinds of iron so if
there is you know a little bit of a
difference in the shape of this little
shoulder there could be a shoulder here
that could vary by different kinds of
minerals like this very subtle shift in
in peak position may be meaningful and
currently there isn't a whole lot of
information in the literature about
these fine distinctions between iron
minerals and soil so this could add a
really could add some really good
information to that this spectrum so
hematite has been image before with eels
so this is a spectrum in the literature
so it's quite similar and also which has
been pretty well established is that the
ratio of L 3 and L 2 these two peaks
is a function of the sample oxidize to
reduce iron content so that's really
convenient and that's how we can use
eels to kind of discern in3 and iron too
so there's a pretty pretty consistent
relationship between the ratio of those
Peaks so you could have hematite which
is theoretically 100% oxidized iron and
then something like FeO a which is
theoretically 0% oxidized iron and be
able to kind of map in the spectrum a
wide variety of different redox states
and iron which is really a useful tool
for oxygen you can see that the spectrum
starts to look a lot Messier which
really takes away a lot of the
conclusions you can draw from it but
there is a pretty apparent difference
between the ratio of a and B in this
spectrum and it turns out that that is
related to the degree of oxidation and
this is also a very consistent
predictable trend so you can use that to
determine the iron oxygen ratio which is
another really useful tool and finally
for haematite and ger tight this is the
valence region the really low loss is
starting just above zero up to about 60
and so there isn't a whole lot of really
great information here you have carbon
coming from the grid that we've prepared
the samples on but you do have an iron
em edge here so that's really good for
as like an independent confirmation that
iron is present and we might be able to
get some information from that as well
so just quickly as to whether a lot of
minerals that we've analyzed so far a
gibbsite and hydroxyapatite so looking
at aluminum calcium and phosphorus
aluminum is really hard to get eel
spectrum for because it is in the low
loft range and as I mentioned there's a
lot of overlap there so that's a
challenge which is a little unfortunate
because a woman of course is very common
in soil and a very important part of of
mineral interactions and just quickly
this is a list of the remaining elements
or the reigning mineral
that I have to analyze as I mentioned
some volcanic mineral is a low fan and a
mogul light some kind of normal
crystalline clays and then also iron
oxides that represent that range of iron
oxidation and we have started working on
some carbon standards an issue with that
is they are much less resistant to
damage from the electron beam than iron
minerals and also typically when you
have any example that goes into the
microscope you have to clean it with a
plasma an oxygen plasma before it goes
in so that it doesn't contaminate with
just things floating around in the
microscope but of course these are
carbon compounds and cleaning them with
plasma would kind of just burn them away
which would be kind of useless
so we don't have a good way to clean
them and so this ends up posing a huge
problem with carbon contamination so in
order to get around that we're working
on doing yields at very low temperature
called cryo eels which helps eliminate
carbon contamination and then also using
alternative sample cleaning one example
is critical point drying so next I'm
just gonna give a quick overview of my
proposed work and these simplified
mixtures this isn't something that I
started yet so I'd be glad to hear any
input you might have in in this and or
suggestions and so basically these are
going to be simplified systems and a
kind of a classic adsorption isotherm
type approach based on some specific
hypothesized interactions and then
followed by analysis of the particles
themselves with eels to see if we can
kind of really unequivocally determine
what is going on at that interface so
this is just one example of one of my
proposed combinations so this would be
using a polar carbon shown here just
generically as our COOH and a nonpolar
carbon with a generic carbon chain and
Amogh light another again one of the
volcanic minerals so one hypothesis is
that the polar carbon will be involved
and covalent bonding but only at the
edges or the ends of the Mogul a tube or
at broken sites on the surface and that
the nonpolar carbon may not interact at
all or it could be involved in some kind
of secondary association with the polar
carbon so just to give you an idea of
the spatial distribution that we might
see you could see just pull our carbon
at the ends and nonpolar carbon not
associated at all we could see it
everywhere or just in broken sites and
nonpolar not associated or nonpolar
could go to the ends or it could cover
the whole thing oh there are lots of
different possibilities here but what is
great about this technique is that we'll
be able to see you know a difference
between this carbon and this carbon and
be able to assign where it is spatially
in this system which is really useful
and then next one of the proposed
incubations or adsorption experiments
would involve a sequence of reducing
conditions and oxidizing conditions
reducing oxidizing reducing oxidizing to
try to encourage iron Co precipitation
with carbon so there has been some
recent work about spatial differences
between carbon that's just adsorbed to
the surface of oxidized iron versus
carbon that's just physically
intercalated in the structure of a co
precipitate between iron and carbon so
this is just something that has a really
interesting spatial characteristic which
is really the benefit of the technique
that I'm using so it's important to
select things that have some kind of
interesting spatial information so
finally I'm going to show you some
preliminary results from actual analysis
of real soils which is kind of the
ultimate goal of this work as I
mentioned earlier the main challenges
here are preventing damage to the sample
eliminating that carbon resin
maintaining the spatial distribution
within an aggregate and then also being
able to analyze both carbon and the min
chemistry and so similarly to the cryo
eels I mentioned for analyzing the
carbon standards we're gonna be using
cryo fin or focused ion beam milling to
prepare the samples and hopefully this
will account for a few of the
methodological considerations and then
followed by that we will be using cryo
eel so everything is frozen from
beginning to end in water which is a
more natural matrix than carbon resin
and as you might have guessed my initial
soil samples will be from volcanic soils
from a model ecosystem with mineral
control on carbon turnover so just a
quick overview of the soils that I'm
using right now are collected from
Hawaii by collaborators Katie grant
who's here and Lou dairy and Earth and
Atmospheric Sciences this particular
sample is characterized as a Waimea silt
loam and it's about in the middle range
of soil age around 350,000 years old and
so it's characterized by those
short-range ordered or semi crystalline
minerals that I mentioned earlier
so these are some scanning electron
microscope images just of intact
aggregates just to give you an idea what
they look like and how variable they are
so you can see that you know you have
some that are kind of lumpy and some
that are kind of smooth some that are
stretched out so even in the aggregate
shape there's a lot of variability these
were collected from deeper soils and
also from a system that has relatively
high iron and carbon content and they
are well drained so they're probably
dominated by oxidized iron I selected
aggregates in the range of about 53 to
150 micron diameter so micro aggregates
and this is for ease of analysis it's
just a better size to use and also these
micro aggregates may have really stable
mineral interactions so there's a little
cartoon of how we start to section the
aggregates so first they're hydrated
slowly with
a humidifier and then just dropped in a
little bead of water
flash frozen and liquid nitrogen and
then cut into sections using a cryo
ultra microtome or a diamond blade and
then it ends up on a copper grid in a
thin section that still has ice around
it and it stays frozen so then if you
can visualize it this is now that grid
looking from above so each of these
little blobs are sections of carbon so
you can see they're kind of variable but
if you were to look at them from the
side they are actually relatively flat
on both sides amazing grants a really
interesting technique and they kind of
cover a range of shapes some of them
kind of break apart on natural breaking
point some of them look like pork chops
I think some of them look like tacos but
then you have to find the one that just
looks just right and that's the one you
go with so then after you have your
perfect sections that you want to try to
look at you then in the FIB which is the
focused ion beam you have a beam of
gallium ions that come down at an angle
and kind of cut out a wedge out of the
head of the sample so you end up with a
really thin area at the bottom and then
just sort of the normal sample thickness
at the top and you can see that in each
of these images here we have our wedges
with only the very edge of the sample
probably thin enough for eels so it's
getting down to a really small area for
analysis and so you kind of have to get
a little bit lucky that you catch a
really interesting feature in that tiny
area but we fortunately did last week
and hopefully more to come so this is
just some some very preliminary results
for some of our initial imaging so this
is just one of those sections and then
one of a tiny area of one of these
sections then blown up much bigger and
then this tiny area blown up bigger here
and then finally a elemental map of that
region
so this is an electron dispersive x-ray
so it's a very coarse scale map but you
can see that we have carbon just
exciting and you can see this area here
is relatively homogeneous carbon which
is nice it's not mixed up with a lot of
other elements and then we have a
particle of that of mostly aluminum it
also has oxygen no silicon so it's
probably an aluminum oxide however this
is a little bit of a problem we also
have gallium where could that have come
from of course the the gallium ion beam
right so gallium likes to deposit itself
on the sample sometimes so this is
something we need to be aware of and
make sure that it's not changing our
signals to substantially you'll notice
though that it's really concentrated in
the aluminum area and hardly any signal
at all in the carbon which is nice
because then we can be able to analyze
the carbon without worrying about
gallium but this is something we need to
consider for future analyses so now
going even smaller we have this area of
carbon and aluminum blown up to a STM
image or stem image so this is your
carbon here and then each of the areas
of different contrasts are a higher
higher atomic weight elements so they
show differently and then even more
magnification we then have carbon and we
can start to see this interface with a
mineral that we have putative lead
determined is aluminum and then even one
more image this is the highest
resolution I have we have carbon and
then this kind of fuzzy but still kind
of distinct interface so just something
to note here this scale bar is 50
nanometers so when I mentioned next ask
that the resolution is 25 to 50
nanometers just imagine that half of
this or the whole thing is just one
whole pixel so this is a much better
spatial resolution already even at just
this scale then we could get with next
apps which is a really exciting thing
also exciting we collected a carbon
kedge yellow spectrum from this area
it's my knowledge the first in real soil
without a carbon resident that's kind of
an exciting day it's not a particularly
distinctive spectrum but there are a few
things that even just with very
preliminary analysis we can start to see
so there is no peak at 285 which is
characteristic of aromatic carbon and
very consistent across all types of
carbon for our next apps which is mostly
related to Yale's data if you have these
two kind of indistinct pre peaks at
about 287 and 289 evie and they could
really be a whole bunch of different
things could be shift of aromatic carbon
with an oxygen or nitrogen or could be
aliphatic carbon 289 could be carboxylic
acids or amines or alcohol so you can
see the value of determining the carbon
reference library and being in analyzing
real soils because we can really start
to link these Peaks and their
characteristics with known functional
groups we also have a aligned scan which
basically takes points along a line that
you draw on the image so we can start to
kind of get a range across a gradient so
first in the adjacent carbon region this
is the spectrum I just showed and then
starting to get closer to the edge you
can see that the spectrum starts to get
a lot Messier lots of variability here
and that's because it starts to get
thicker as you get closer to the mineral
so as we continue to prepare more
samples we really want to try to
maximize the the thinness of the of the
sample it's just going to continue to be
something to work on but you can already
see that there are some differences
potentially in the relationship of those
first two pre Peaks just out at this
outer edge and then at a point closer to
the interface
there's there quite a few new new small
Peaks lots of variability this is going
to take a lot of analysis to get what
might be meaningful out of the spectrum
and then of course the more the less
signal-to-noise ratio we can get the
better it will be at being able to pull
out features of these spectra and then
finally one more on the other side and
you can see that the first pre peak is
almost gone so the meaning of this is
going to take a lot of analysis but it's
kind of an exciting development to see
that there are differences across this
mineral Carbon region so just to wrap up
the next thing is that I'm going to be
working on continued sample preparation
for the thin sections continued analysis
and then working on linking carbon
compound chemistry and the interface and
then just in general continuing to
analyze standards the simplified mixture
experiments and then lots and lots and
lots of data analysis forever and ever
to get meaningful information from this
from this data so I just like to
acknowledge my funding which is from the
across scale biogeochemistry and climate
aigrette and then also we've been
working with the Cornell Center for
Materials Research which is a really
really essential piece of this we
wouldn't definitely not be able to do it
without our collaborators and physics
David Muller who works with Eels and
Lena fitting crookedest who does fib and
then their grad students have collected
a lot of this data with me and have been
really really helpful also my thesis
committee my advisor is Johannes Lehmann
who's not here today unfortunately and
then also we've banned them lots of
support from my lab and the support
staff at the CCM are so there are tons
and tons of really interesting resources
which obviously you can't read but if
you ever want to talk to about where any
I got any of this information from I'd
be glad to discuss it further and
finally thank you so much for your
attention do you have any questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu